I'm not stupid so if I was the only
person I've never known to have been
followed home or touched I wouldn't have
these opinions
there are so many men in the world there
is but you've also got men that are
rocking a graping and killing and not
getting the repercussions yeah but the
thing is why why hang on this is the
thing why is it that you keep hanging on
yeah the trauma and the negativity
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait when men have shown themselves like
we said earlier in this situation to
build the world in which you live men
have built the world in which you live
they've built this how they probably
built this this apartment you probably
got here on the public transport they
built that men have literally built the
um the world in which you live in and
you think it's okay to just sit there
and be I feel like men are bad women